[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le journal de tv soixante
dix huit pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale bienvenue dans cette
édition du jeudi 19 septembre voici les
titres la grande page dédiée ce soir au
patrimoine ce week-end ce sont les 36e
journée européenne
focus sur l'orangerie du château d'anne
au cours à gargenville retenu par le
loto du patrimoine elle nous parlerons
aussi de l'opération sauvons nos
monuments lancé par le parisien et la
start-up d'artagnan il a pris la route
pour sensibiliser au sida jérémy chalon
et sa boucle du ruban rouge était de
passage hier avec mon la ville a signé l
appel pour demander à la france
d'augmenter sa dotation au fonds mondial
de lutte contre le sida
et puis à la veille du début de la coupe
du monde de rugby rencontre avec un
espoir qui a commencé sa carrière à dire
ça il est au bar et il a connu cet été
sa première sélection avec l'équipe de
france des moins de 18 ans mais
l'actualité du jour d'abord c'est ce
déplacement officiel nicole belloubet
était ce matin à la caf la caisse
d'allocations familiales des yvelines
situé à versailles accompagné de la
secrétaire d'état christelle du boss la
ministre de la justice est venu lancer
un nouveau dispositif le service public
de versement des pensions alimentaires
à l'heure actuelle une pension
alimentaire sur trois demeurent impayées
avec le nouveau système la pension sera
désormais versé par l'intermédiaire de
la caf à la demande de l'un des parents
ou du juge
et dans deux jours ce sont les 36e
journées européennes du patrimoine à
suivre dans ce journal quelques idées de
sorties à saint quentin en yvelines et
mais d'abord j'accueille mon invité
c'est romain delaune bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le co2 à la start up et
d'artagnan vous avez lancé avec nos
confrères du parisien
souvent nos monuments c'est un appel à
projets pour aider à la préservation du
patrimoine en ile de france
beaucoup d'initiatives dont celle ci
mais d'autres aussi pour le patrimoine
on pense bien sûr à ce loto 1 qui a
lancé il ya quelques semaines sa
deuxième saison l'orangerie du château
d'anne cours à gargenville sera aidé par
cette opération
c'est le seul monument et des yvelines
sélectionnés par la mission berne
découverte de ce patrimoine avec maxime
abolin et margot du roi laissé à
l'abandon lors du rachat du château
d'alincourt l'orangerie a été acquise
par la mairie en 2015 c'est treillage en
bois fait main mais surtout son plafond
peint avec des motifs des feuillages en
font un lieu unique
ce bâtiment donc à ce côté atypique et
original c'est que c'est que c'est un
bâtiment quasiment unique voilà donc une
orange une orangerie haïk aménagé de
cette façon et il n'existe pas d'autres
en france donc c'est ce qui est aussi un
petit peu séduit les membres du jury qui
ont sélectionné c'est cet orange reid
par l'intermédiaire de la fondation du
patrimoine
mais le monument historique est mal en
point il y a quelques années la poutre
centrale s'est écroulée à cause des
intempéries
des travaux ont donc été réalisés par la
municipalité pour sécuriser l'orangerie
la rénovation est cependant loin d'être
terminée il faudrait un million et demi
d'euros pour la remettre en état
pour commencer par refaire toute la
toiture qui est une toiture un peu à la
mansart en ardoise donc c'est déjà par
ça qu'il faut commencer pour la mettre
totalement hors d'eau et la senior
complètement
ensuite il faut il ya une reprise totale
de l'intérieur de la municipalité
voudrait que l'orangerie deviennent par
la suite un lieu culturel c'est
orangerie qui permettra donc une fois
qu'elle sera rénové 2
de l'affecter principalement l usage
culturel donc en faire un lieu
d'exposition en faire un lieu de concert
un lieu des changes un lieu de
conférences
voilà donc tout à vocation culturelle
la durée des travaux dépendra des sommes
d'argent récoltées lors du loto ainsi
que des donations deux mécènes mais la
mairie estime qu'il faudra cinq à sept
ans avant que l'orangerie du château
d'anet cours puissent de nouveau
accueillir du public et le super loto du
patrimoine est au programme ce week-end
des tickets à 3 ou 15 euros sont
disponibles chez votre buraliste pas que
ce loto du patrimoine je le disais en
début d'édition d'autres opérations
aussi à lancer pour la sauvegarde de nos
monuments franciliens
romain delaune votre start-up d'artagnan
a donc lancé avec le parisien sauvons
nos monuments c'est un appel à projets
pour aider à la préservation
préservation du patrimoine en
ile-de-france et dans l'oise
est ce que l'objectif c'est d'être
complémentaire avec ce genre d'opération
dont on vient de parler le loto du
patrimoine puisque tous les monuments où
on pas pouvoir être aidées par ce biais
c'est tout à fait complémentaires le
loto du patrimoine c'est une très belle
visibilité pour cette cause et cette
cause nationale qui est la préservation
du patrimoine est effectivement avec vos
confrères du parisien et la région ile
de france aussi qui va apporter une aide
financière aux projets qui sont
sélectionnés sur tout le territoire
francilien plus ce département de l'oise
et bien finalement on va permettre à des
monuments et brad de récolter des fonds
auprès de la communauté d'artagnan des
lecteurs du parisien et une subvention
de la région ile-de-france donc sur ces
départements franciliens éloize puisque
ce sont les zones de couverture de nos
confrères du parisien
présentez-nous votre start-up pourquoi
il s'intéresse justement à cette
question du patrimoine
si vous voulez dire ce qu'on a lancé
d'artagnan il ya quatre ans
on a voulu créer une très grande
communauté de défenseurs du patrimoine
mais autour de projets construits se
dire qu'on met le patrimoine et les
projets patrimoine y est au centre de ce
que nous proposons sur le site de
d'artagnan et on accompagne nos
propriétaires de monuments qu'ils soient
privés ou publics à construire
finalement des campagnes de collecte de
fonds et les aider aussi dans leur
réflexion de savoir si collecte telle
somme comment est-ce qu'ils vont le
dépenser pour justement restaurer le
monument est aussi devenir un pôle
d'attractivité serre que préserver un
monument ça contribue nécessairement
attractivité touristique d'un territoire
et les personnes qui vont visiter des
lieux qui sont en restauration qui sont
restaurés par vont aussi aller au
restaurant dans les hôtels dans les
chambres d'hôtes et donc forcément ça
bénéficie à tout le territoire
alors je reviens à l'opération avec le
parisien qui aurait dû je crois être
lancée plus tôt il ya eu un événement
forcément important malheureux pour la
france c'est l'instant dit notre dame de
paris ça repousser quelque peu le
lancement de cette campagne
du coup ça repousse et bien évidemment
voilà le je vais dire que le monde s'y
arrêter mais en tout cas le monde du
patrimoine c'est un petit peu arrêté
pendant pendant quelques jours et
quelques semaines avec avec ce drame
on a souhaité dans cette opération qui
est qui et qui est assez unique de deux
acteurs privés un média une start up
avec pour la première fois aussi une
région qui s'engagent à nos côtés et on
pense justement que le public qu'on va
réussir à fédérer comme vous lisiez en
début d'émission sera tout à fait
complémentaire avec celui que le loto va
toucher et finalement la combinaison des
deux fait que wade semble beaucoup plus
substantiel pourront être collectées en
2009 dans les années à venir parce que
le l'opération on a reçu énormément de
dossiers déjà aura certainement vocation
à se renouveler en 2020 donc on est très
heureux et puis j'appelle tous ceux qui
nous regardent et d'habitants des
yvelines justement à déposer des
dossiers sur le site sauvons nos
monuments point fr qui peut justement
déposé un dossier où on rappelle juste
que l'on précise que cet appel à projets
est lancé jusqu'au 13 octobre qui peut
candidater
tout le monde peut candidater
on souhaite aider des tout petits
projets des petites chapelles des petits
moulins des grands châteaux aussi s'ils
le souhaitent qu'on soit un acteur privé
ou un acteur public on peut candidater
qu'on soit classée ou pas on peut
candidater
est ce qu'il va être intéressant c'est
que finalement avec le parisien et la
région ile de france
on va se réunir en comité on va
sélectionner deux projets par
département et ensuite c'est le public
qui va décider et qu'il va choisir
finalement un projet par département il
ya un vote c'est important de donner le
dernier mot finalement aux internautes
c'est important de nemo public surtout
aux citoyens qui vont décider d'affecter
leurs dons de partager l'information sur
les réseaux sociaux et nous on trouve
que finalement nous on a l'initiative
mais si finalement le public qui va
décider le financement d'un projet
choisir son préféré
voilà et puis ceux qui seront pas
sélectionnés on lancera comme des
opérations avec eux après après
l'initiative non vous avez parlé du
calendrier donc 18 projets sélectionnés
dans un premier temps dont deux qui
concerneront les yvelines y en aura deux
pour par département la sélection a' va
se faire comment ce que vous avez dit
vous avez reçu beaucoup de dossiers
comment les départager
alors si vous voulez nous les projets on
l'est on les qualifie c'est à dire que
on prend contact avec les porteurs de
projets on examine avec eux leurs
dossiers forcément un porteur de projet
qui a déjà des devis et qui c'est qui va
engager en montant important et pas
forcément important de travaux en 2020
forcément il va marquer des points par
rapport à qu'un qui ajuste une idée mais
qui l'a pas encore couchés sur le papier
donc on va privilégier les projets mûrs
ceux qui sont prêts à lancer une
opération de financement participatif
délai la faim devant 18 projets il en
restera neuf 9 gagnants qui seront
choisis par le public le vote se fait
sur le site internet entre le 26 octobre
et le 4 novembre et donc du coup notre
grand gagnant pardon il y en aura un
débat un par département pas de jaloux
comme ça et qu est-ce qui a la clé de
concrètement pour le vainqueur pour le
vainqueur il ya plusieurs choses
il ya bien sûr une couverture médiatique
importante de la part du parisien que ce
soit dans les éditions départementales
et nationales
il ya un accompagnement de d'artagnan
pour aider le porteur de projet à monter
une opération de financement
participatif donc on à la fois sur la
partie financement et communication et
la région ile de france peut apporter un
complément de financement qui peut quand
même aller jusqu'à 300 mille euros par
projet à condition bien sûr que le
proposa n'engage aussi des travaux donc
finalement il ya tout à gagner se faire
connaître
avoir des sous pour se développer et
puis et puis je pense que sympathique
aussi d'avoir la l'approbation du public
est en tout cas sur son territoire on
vous le disiez tout le monde peut
candidater comment on dépose un dossier
justement c'est très simple si on a fait
le site internet le plus simple et le
plus lisible possible il suffit de se
connecter sur www.solvay.com du mans
point fr le calendrier est expliquée il
ya une petite fiche à remplir et dès
lors que vous avez rempli votre fiche
pas nos équipes prennent contact avec
vous et puis vous pose des questions
pour savoir dans quelle catégorie vous m
s qui effectivement vous êtes prêts pour
2019 ou s'il fera peut-être plutôt
attendre 2020 on voit le portail ans
s'affiche à l'écran vous le disiez
depuis le 2 septembre soit le depuis le
début' du lancement de cette opération
beaucoup de dossiers ont déjà été
déposés il ya du succès pour cet open il
ya il ya beaucoup de succès
malgré le fait qu'elle soit la rentrée
des classes on a eu à peu près une
cinquantaine de dossiers surtout les
tous les départements concernés quelques
très beaux dossiers aussi dans les
yvelines voilà on espère en tout cas
d'ici le 13 octobre il reste un petit
mois finalement pour déposer d'autres
dossiers et ce qui va aussi nous
permettre d'identifier des monuments qui
ont besoin d aide
encore une fois je le rappelle
l'opération et est bien construite et
très belle mais ça n'empêchera pas
évidemment à ceux qui souhaitaient pas
retenu pour cette année de travail et
que l'année prochaine et l'objectif si
vous voulez c'est vraiment d'aider tout
le monde il ya besoin de tellement
d'argent pour le patrimoine qu'il faut
absolument concentrer toutes les
initiatives toutes les forces conçoit
une start-up privé comme nous ou
d'autres acteurs nous rappelle la date
l'appel à projets est ouvert jusqu'au 13
octobre les dossiers sont à déposer sur
le site sauvons nos monuments merci
romain delaune merci à vous de la
start-up d'artagnan merci d'être passé
en plateau vous parliez tout à l'heure
du soutien financier l'ile-de-france
d'une france qui a de son côté aussi
lancé ces assises du patrimoine
l'objective c de mieux valoriser le
patrimoine et ses métiers développées
aussi des financements innovants pour la
sauvegarde de ces monuments l'île de
france ça a été validée en conseil
régional vient aussi de labelliser 23
sites comme patrimoine d'intérêt
régional 2019 cette distinction permet à
des éléments non classés et non inscrits
aux monuments historiques d'être protégé
les propriétaires de ces lieux peuvent
demander des aides régionales pour la
préservation dans les yvelines vous les
voyez s'afficher six nouveaux lieux ont
reçu ce label tir groupé pour les gars
avec celle de villennes-sur-seine de
bougival la selle et de versailles rive
droite qui a été construite en 1839 avec
une façade néoclassique autre site la
maison de faire de dampierre ou encore
la bourse d'affrètement à conflans
sainte honorine vestiges de l'activité
batelière enfin elles ont été réalisées
dans les années à 80 et 90 les arts les
arts les oeuvres d'art urbain à saint
quentin en yvelines est la porte de
paris de piotr kowalski meta 2006
mercado ou encore la perspective de
martha panne forme un parcours entre
montigny le bretonneux et aiguille en
cours ce week-end ce sont donc les 36e
journées du patrimoine un événement en
avant première dès le week-end dernier à
maurepas ou art
muret métiers artisanaux du moyen-âge
étaient de sortie un campement médiéval
s'est installé à la ferme prud'hommes
retour sur cet événement avec manon
varaldo remontons le temps et revenons
au moyen-âge les morts pas un ont pu
retourner au xvème siècle avec la
reconstitution d'un village médiéval
mémorial connaissent bien leur histoire
est d'ailleurs me semble très passionné
en fait hein c'est vrai que deux d'année
en année on s'aperçoit qu'en fait
l'histoire est important pour pour les
bords pas et on frise historique sur le
moyen-âge création de photophores pour
enfants ou encore reconstitution d'une
cathédrale en 3d des animations
proposées par l'association mort pas
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
suite à l'émotion suscitée par
l'incendié de notre dame de paris on a
créé cette maquette qui permet
d'apprendre le nom des pièces déjà les
contreforts le chevet le transept
on recherche des architectes et quand
les enfants arrivent en leur dis bravo
c'était l'architecte que nous attendions
c'était bien un atelier ludique qui a
plu aux nombreux enfants présents
retrouver les pièces c'est un peu
compliqué parce que elle se ressembler
un peu donc savoir de quelques têtes
m'étais un peu difficile mais après
c'est ça a été un peu plus loin des
armures détente de l'époque médiéval
installé par les regrattiers d'histoire
notre propos c'est de reconstituer la
vie que pouvait rencontrer quelqu'un qui
serait rentré dans une bourgade de nos
régions là en ile de france
le campement médiéval immerge le public
dans le quotidien de l'époque
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir les
métiers de la laine et un tisserand mais
aussi les loisirs de l'époque échasses
chant et art je vais essayer aussi l'art
puis c'est un instrument qui est peu
fréquent sur les fêtes médiévales et qui
est assez peu connue finalement en
dehors des grands arbres de concert ce
campement médiéval de maurepas a permis
à petits et grands de replonger dans
l'histoire et le patrimoine de cette
ville qui possède son donjon de cette
époque
elle les journées du patrimoine qui se
poursuivent ce week-end à saint quentin
en yvelines
au programme du classique avec des
visites guidées au théâtre et au
vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux on en parlait tout à l'heure
de la perspective une promenade dans le
parc des sources de la bière ou un
voyage dans l'espace et grâce aux
nombreuses animations proposées à
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
c'est à guyancourt ou au choix retour
dans le passé au sein du site
remarquable de l'abbaye port royal des
champs de magny les hameaux visite
conférence le samedi multitude
d'animations à la commanderie à
elancourt des visites guidées jeu de
piste ou a découverte libre à plaisir
c'est original
outre le château l'église saint-pierre
un circuit est organisée dans le
quartier du val hibou des fresques ont
été peintes sur les murs des bâtiments
ou sont encore en cours de réalisation
enfin la verrière le château s'offrent à
vous le dimanche bâti au xvième siècle
avec ses jardins confié aux plus grands
paysagistes de l'époque le site est
aujourd'hui la propriété de la mgen ses
idées de sorties et bien d'autres encore
à développer dans l'émission à 7,8 à
loisir présenté par wilfrid richy sur tv
soixante dix 8,7 après ce journal voilà
ce qu'on pouvait vous dire sur ses 36e
journées du patrimoine
[Musique]
et dans le reste de l'actualité
yvelinois cette initiative pour
sensibiliser à la lutte contre le sida à
vélo à pied en courant et jérémy chalon
parcourt la france une mobilisation à
qui rassemble plusieurs associations et
représentants politiques pour signer un
appel qui sera envoyée au président de
la république mathilde et demi et
vecmont c'est la ville étape qu'il a
choisi dans les yvelines pour s'arrêter
et faire signer son appel du ruban rouge
g lamisha l'on parcourt la france à vélo
à pied et en courant pour sensibiliser
les citoyens pour la lutte contre le
sida
une mobilisation qui lui rappelle que
les français ne se sentent pas toutes
concernées
arrivée à la mairie des vêtements voilà
donc en gros on va diffuser de
l'information va apporter de la
pédagogie pour expliquer que le sida ça
concerne tout le monde qui on peut y
mettre fin
ghislaine ce n'est la mer des vêtements
se sent très impliquée par cette
démarche et se désole que sa ville soit
la seule à avoir accepté de recevoir la
boucle du ruban rouge et le sida mais
également le paludisme cc à ces trans
partisan
donc non je suis assez je suis assez
étonné du fait qu'il n'ait pas voulu
accueillir 7 7 cette démarche et je
pense qu enfin tout le monde doit être
mobilisée contre contre cette maladie
pour l'association aides il était
primordial que la boucle passe en île de
france car c'est la région la plus
touchée par l'épidémie
il ya des personnes qui sont amis des
deux personnes qui n'ont pas accès aux
soins et au dépistage et d'avoir voilà
la maire d'une commune qui qui décide de
s'engager de signer notre appel pour
nous c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'essentiel la boucle du ruban rouge
sera donc bouclé le 10 octobre à lyon
après 1600 km pour intervenir sur le
fonds mondial de la lutte contre le sida
on parle sport la coupe du monde de
rugby débute débute demain au japon à la
veille de cet événement
rencontre avec un jeune espoir français
léo barré a commencé le rugby au club de
versailles set et il a connu sa première
sélection en équipe de france des moins
de 18 ans son portrait signé par nicolas
landry en plein mois de juillet au
centre national du rugby à marcoussis
l'équipe de france moins de 18 ans est
en pleine préparation pour une tournée
en afrique du sud
au programme trois matchs contre les sud
africains les anglais le pays de galles
parmi les joueurs sélectionnés un jeune
yvelinois léobard et il est un joueur
complet
d'abord il est très athlétique il a une
grandeur qui est intéressante pour
pouvoir lutter sur les balles aériennes
c'est aussi un très bon communicant un
très bon leader pour sa première
sélection les eaux s'est illustré en
inscrivant un essai face à l'afrique du
sud le premier match de la tournée
remporté avec succès 43 19 parlait
français ça représente beaucoup de jeu
pour l'équipe de france
sportivement ça m'a fait progresser au
niveau rugbystique j'ai appris que le
gie appliquer ce qu'était le haut niveau
et humainement ça
bien fait mûrir et surtout grandi je
suis sorti grandi de cette tournée
aujourd'hui les eaux entame sa troisième
année au pôle espoir de lakanal à sceaux
une structure gérée par la fédération
française de rugby pour former au sport
de haut niveau en plus de ses études
le rugbyman yvelinois s'entraîne plus de
10 heures par semaine ça représente une
étape dans la formation d'un jeune de
passer par un peu au l'espoir on est
passé pas une obligation de passer par
un peu l'histoire mais je trouve que
c'est sa part fait progresser quand même
le joueur crée des déséquilibres
c'est un joueur déjà qui est
physiquement que des belles qualités
et puis après il est assez complet sur
la technique individuelle avec bonnes
passes bon jeu au pied
ce qui reste à travailler un petit peu
c'est sa capacité à dire les espaces
libres face à des défenses très
pressante et quand on est très près de
la ligne
en fin d'après midi direction le stade
jules ladoumègue à massy pour un
entraînement avec son club sa cinquième
année dans cette équipe
le rugby léobard il l'a dans le sang
grâce à son grand père et son père tous
les deux anciens joueurs du rugby club
de versailles
il commence à l'âge de 6 ans ça fait
trois générations où ça se transmet de
père en fils chez la famille bach et on
est tous demi d'ouverture ou demi de
mêlée donc on aime dire analyser la
vitesse la technique on n'aime pas trop
le le contact même s'il faut faut
s'envoyer
aujourd'hui je me sens très toujours
versailles et que massicot enfin j'ai
commencé à verser mon père était
versailles et mes grands-parents
versailles et mon grand-père versailles
et donc je me sentirai toujours
versailles il est repéré rapidement par
un dirigeant de massy lorsqu'il joue en
catégorie moins de 12 ans cette saison
il joue avec l'équipe crabos du club
essonnien avec des entraînements le
mercredi et vendredi soir je connais les
eaux depuis qu'il a 10 ans quand il
jouait à versailles et il frappait dans
l'oeil de tout le monde et il n'a pas
mis longtemps à le repérer là mon
objectif principal de cette année c'est
de faire le ton à destination avec les
moins de 18 ans
et suivant ça je verrai les contacts que
j'ai avec les autres clubs
donc pourquoi pas rester encore quelques
années à massy ou
ça sera à voir à la fin de l'année pour
l'instant pour l'instant je me base sur
une bonne année à massy une voie royale
pour ce versailles et avec l'objectif
d'intégrer un jour le quinze de france
avant de refermer ce journal cet
événement samedi à la salle de la torah
voisins le bretonneux une jolie la
soirée concert est au programme
ouverture des portes à 20 heures trois
groupes locaux à la fiche de cet
événement préparé par joly prod aimé ta
sauce bonsoir sandra chars vous êtes
chargé de communication a meta saussez
bonsoir thomas salazar on sort et vous
êtes jeune cinéaste est également
musicien et membre deux jolies prod
première question pour vous c'est le
deuxième la deuxième soirée de ce
concept des jolies soirées qu'elle est
justement le concept alors là j'ai les
jolies soirées c'est des soirées
événementielles en fait autour d'un
thème
on avait déjà fait une si jolie soirée
cinéma en fait qui mettait en valeur des
jeunes cinéastes locaux et là du coup
c'est la jolie soirée concert qui met du
coup en valeur des groupes locaux cette
fois en fait c'est le but des jolies
soirées c'est de mettre en valeur des
talents artistiques locaux dans tous les
domaines artistiques pourquoi justement
les mettre en valeur ses talents
artistiques locaux et bien parce que
dans les yvelines en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de talents en fait qui ne sont
pas forcément connus assez reconnus à
leur juste valeur et du coup ça permet
en fait avec les jolies soirées on peut
les on peut les
les mettre en avant m il a demandé à
mettre en avant pour pour découvrir en
fait le talent et essayer pourquoi pas
de lait de les faire de faire monter une
étape pour aller faire connaître et
pouvoir après les produire par exemple
ou ou alors à les faire connaître à
d'autres gens qui vont en parler autour
d'eux et du poulet donc sa puce peut
être relancer une carrière l'idée c'est
aussi de créer un échange autour de ces
soirées bien sûr en échange c'est
important que les que les gens se
connaissent en fait c'est à dire de
faire rencontrer du coup même dans les
groupes à la jolie soirée que qu'il se
rend compte qu'ils rencontrent des gens
dans le public qui ont été intéressés et
du coup les faire connaître et wii et
wii a gagné en popularité en tout cas et
et marcher ensemble que les groupes
artistiques en tous cas marche en marche
ensemble pour monter des projets alors
vous allez monter ce projet justement
avec une association locale mais ta
sauce voilà c'est normal de s'appuyer
sur ces associations locales pour
organiser ces soirées qui bien sûr mais
ta sauce nous a beaucoup aidés
d'ailleurs on l'est on les remercie
oui bien sûr ben en fait je lis prod
c'est une petite association qui défend
une petite et en créer une nouvelle
et du coup je pense que ça a été
important de s'appuyer sur matériaux ce
qui nous a acquis qui nous ont beaucoup
aidés pour créer ce concept de jolis de
joli concert du coup et oui c'est
important de créer des synergies dans
les associations parce que ça permet de
faire des belles choses
forcément on n'a pas forcément toujours
les moyens les forcément les contacts et
tout donc je pense que se mettre
ensemble en tout cas c'est important
c'est pareil du côté mais ta sauce est
intéressant oui de créer des événements
des synergies avec les associations
proposer des événements comme un fait
c'est vrai que sur cette soirée par
exemple on leur laisse carte blanche ça
veut dire que c'est eux qui décident de
la programmation nous ça permet de
renouveler un petit peu notre
programmation justement enfin la
programmation on a l'habitude de faire
et puis et puis voilà alors mes tableaux
c'est une association qu'on ne présente
plus ou presque en tout cas pour les
téléspectateurs qui vous qui ne vous
connaissent pas votre idée c'est de
mettre en avant promouvoir les musiques
actuelles c'est ça oui c'est ça en fait
on est là pour promouvoir les musiques
actuelles et amplifiées et ans
on fait la promotion des groupes locaux
amateurs ou professionnels en ça dépend
et le but c'est de les accueillir et d
accompagner dans nos studios
d'enregistrement de répétitions puis
après sur notre salle la salle de la
tour dont on s'occupe à l'année et voilà
c'est effectivement le but c'est de les
accompagner de les faire émerger et puis
de d'encourager justement le
développement de nouveaux styles
musicaux aussi un peu alternatif autres
je vais proposer des soirées concerts
vous mêlez justement ces talents locaux
avec des groupes professionnels
ah oui ça arrive exactement et puis
notamment on a des concerts aussi toute
l'année le festival la tour mais les
ouates donc en était à chaque fois et le
but c'est vraiment de mélanger tout ça
tout à fait et de proposer aussi de la
musique à tarifs accessibles parce que
nos concerts sont du coup à des tarifs
totalement accessible à tous à non
l'événement aulas qui arrive c'est cette
jolie soirée concert quel est le
programme de la soirée alors à trois
groupes the walk in roosters bus river
est majeur du coup majeur ça va être
plutôt de la funk hip hop saül il ya un
bassiste et une flûtiste si je ne trompe
pas et c'est ça et du coup voilà ils ont
des influences vraiment diverses
on va avoir vu ce qui va aussi je pense
quand tu les connais par coeur
oui majeur qui vient du coup de mode
devant moi ghost rider qui vient de
rambouillet lui qui fait de la
cinématique afin pop un petit peu
musique cinématiques c'est vraiment
mettre l'accent en fait sur la
composition des ambiances aussi j'ai eu
la chance de voir en concert et il ya
vraiment l'ambiance est extrêmement bien
travaillé aussi très prix commencée des
ambiances un petit peu mystérieuse on
est on est dedans quand ça c'est
vraiment comme au cinéma un petit peu et
on a aussi du coup c'est moi qui en
ressort ça c'est un groupe rock rock qui
bouge quoi c'est un cancer ça met
beaucoup beaucoup d'ambiance et qui
sortent d'ailleurs qui certes le rhdp
samedi qui sera en vente exclusivement à
la fin de la jolie soirée et on retrouve
toutes les informations sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran je reprécise
juste que la jolie soirée concert c'est
au programme samedi à 20 heures à la
salle de la torah voisin merci sandra
chars merci à thomas salades un salad
est repassé en plateau voilà c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi demain vendredi vous avez rendez
vous avec le 7-8 l'hebdo marylène
iapichino reviendra sur ce qui a fait
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines et le journal revient à dès
lundi en direct à 18h belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]